joining me now David Schoen former Trump
impeachment lawyer and Saul weisenberg
former assistant U.S attorney and Deputy
independent Council gentlemen vote thank
you so much for being here David let me
start with you you've heard the optimism
from the Trump Camp uh what are the
chances something is is quickly
dismissed and if not what what does the
process look like
well I think the the chances uh I I
can't really predict but I think that
there are at least three motions that
ought to be filed immediately after the
arraignment first of all as to the
process you know I've been through this
with this judge a high profile case
they're going to process president Trump
um like they normally do uh take certain
pedigree information and so on and then
he'll go to judge Merchant's courtroom
judgment usually allows a still
photographer to take one picture while
he's sitting at the defendant's table
and he will move through it pretty
quickly question is whether at the
arraignment they'll also set a motion
schedule that's kind of up in the air I
think um but they're going to unseal the
indictment before the arraignments or at
least the lawyers can look at it then I
don't think there was any reason to seal
it until now but that's what they've
chosen to do but anyway I think there
are three motions they should file
immediately after the arraignment one is
a motion to dismiss on statute of
limitations ground very interesting
arguments there one would be a motion to
dismiss and disqualify uh district
attorney Bragg I think based on his
campaign statements specifically
targeting president Trump and promising
to convict him when he wasn't even under
investigation and third I would
personally move to recuse the judge I
think that there's Monkey Business going
on with the judge with the judge
shopping process and I have an historic
basis for making that claim uh but we'll
see I don't I think it's coincidental
that he was a judge on the Trump
organization case and the Bannon case
and now this case and they in the past
have acknowledged the practice of Judge
shopping
yeah it certainly looks like in this
case
um so I got to get your take on this
though because late tonight just moments
ago Michael isikoff reported and this is
just early reporting that Donald Trump
will be charged with 34 felony counts
for falsification of business records
but he will not be put in handcuffs as
has been reported placed in a jail cell
or subject or subjected to a mug shot so
now they're saying no mug shot no
handcuffs but 34 felonies saw your your
reaction if that reporting is correct
well you know spiky Michael isikoff
that's his nickname usually gets his
stories right but like we've talked
about on this show you can gin up a
prosecution whether it be a misdemeanor
or a felony with a lot of counts the key
thing for people to watch
for Pete is what is the substance here
remember what the statute the statute is
falsification of business records which
is a misdemeanor unless you're trying to
cover up another crime so take a look at
what that other crime is if it's a
campaign Finance violation boy that's an
incredibly weak case for reasons I'd be
happy to explain but who knows it could
be something else it could be state tax
law but the key is to look at does it
look like it's Petty or is it something
really substantive
uh your your reaction as well David uh
if they really are foregoing a mug shot
that seems different
um we heard reports of you know two
dozen or 30 counts not necessarily all
of them felonies if that reporting is
correct and again we'll learn tomorrow
um what's your reaction to how the judge
will approach this and how they both
sides will well you know Saul is
absolutely right they often just jack up
the number of counts but I think this
D.A is too Savvy to have this case just
depend on Michael Cohen or or the
McDougall case I think there probably
will be some charges about business
fraud that sort of thing but um I'll
tell you another issue that I think may
come up tomorrow and I'm concerned about
is the idea of a gag order I'm you know
vehemently opposed to them
um I think they have First Amendment
implications sixth amendment
implications make it much more difficult
to defend a case to encourage witnesses
to come forward that sort of thing and I
think there's a great public interest in
this case New York law is pretty good on
this they they have a pretty strict
standard for it uh the judge has to
articulate specific findings and I could
see this judge coming in and talking
about some of the posts that he's seen
and he's not going to put up with this
and that this is a judge who's very
sensitive to the media presence there
and there's been a number of problems in
the past because they don't use
electronic filing in this court it's all
paper filing the media has got to be
very aggressive here in getting full
access to all filings in this case and
to resisting a gag order and especially
a gag order of the breadth that's being
talked about in the Press
Saul former president Trump has been
very critical of this judge I mean can
he get a fear Fair Hearing in a New York
City courtroom con considering what he's
been up against
well I don't know enough about this
particular Judge David would know that
there's no reason to think that he that
he can't get a fair hearing but I think
we need to watch it carefully and if I I
think that if there is a gag order like
David says might happen you're going to
immediately have heavy litigation on
that but something else your viewers
should keep in mind is that in a
criminal case it's often very difficult
to get the actual charges knocked off on
a question of law alone if if it is
based partly on fact unfortunately
sometimes they make often they make the
defendant go through a trial
interesting all right tomorrow we'll
we'll tell us everything we need to know
at least initially David and Saul thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else